Dick and Dale's Exotic Entertainment. We're
ripped, we strip, and you tip.
Oh, hey, Mom.
Do you think that's him?
Until I figure out why it's self-sabotage, I
don't think I'll ever find love.
Rambling on about his horrible love life.
Definitely Sophie's dad.
Hi, there. Are you Dick or Dale?
Dick. Dale passed years ago.
He tried the death-defying Alley-Oop Pole
Flip. Nailed it.
But then got murdered.
I bet he's giving lap dances to angels now.
Dick, did you ever, by chance, attend the music festival, Lollapalooza?
No. Why are you asking me that?
Just a fun icebreaker.
We like to get to know our strippers.
Ellen, may I speak to you by the buttshot wall?
Well, he's lying. We already know he went to Lollapalooza.
Clearly, we can't trust him to answer our
questions honestly.
We got to see if he's got that barbed wire tattoo on his arm.
Ask him to take his shirt off.
You can't just ask a stripper to sample the
merchandise without paying for the goods.
He's not Costco, Ellen.
Follow my lead.
Dick, my friend.
All the wall butts in the world pale in comparison with yours.
Now, I'm in charge of throwing my best friend here,
her bachelorette party.
And I want you to be the stripper.
Oh, I'm flattered, but I've been out of the
game for years.
That is such a shame. Because my dream
bachelorette is a man like you shaking a donk
like that in a face like this.
Please?
I...
You know what? For you, I'll dust this donk
off one last time.
When's the party?
In two hours.
Ah!
Welcome to Straight Ellen's Bachelorette.
We have penis hats, a penis pinata, and a
pineapple upside down penis cake.
That is...
Extremely realistic. The detail is amazing.
Are those pubes made of coconut flakes? It's a triumph.
Oh, there's our entertainment.
Now, remember, ladies, you can look... but you
can't touch.
Not going to be a problem.
Ahoy, landlubbers.
Who's ready to walk my plank?
So... are we waiting for the rest of the guests or-
Nope.
Gang's all here.
What I lack in friends, I make up for in
horniness. So, get dancing!
Okay, Ellen!
Are you ready for me to... shiver your timbers?
Sure, big boy. Drop anchor.
Oh-
That costs extra.
Never mind. Full steam ahead.
That also costs extra.
Just do what we paid for.
Really? He's going one scarf at a time?
Let me try and speed this along.
Take your shirt off, Dick! Woo!
Don't worry, little lady.
All in due time.
It's been an hour. He has to take his shirt off next.
Who strips from the bottom up?
Dick?
What's wrong?
I miss Dale.
I haven't stripped since he passed away.
It just doesn't feel right to go full nude without him here.
Totally understand.
If Ellen and I were a team of strippers and...
And she pulled off a daring stripper move and then
got murdered in a totally unrelated incident,
I don't think I'd ever strip again either.
Yes, you would.
Because you'd know that I'd want you to shake
that thing harder than ever. For me. For us.
And I bet that's what Dale would want for you too.
You're right.
Strip. Strip.
Strip. Strip
Dale!
This is for you!
Strip. Strip. Strip. Strip.
Strip. Strip.
No barbed wire tattoo!
Man!
I mean.
Ohhh, man.